I will say like the show came out it was
number nine on all of Netflix the first
day number six the next day and like the
reception has been insane like way
bigger than I ever thought like how many
how many messages are you getting oh
dude I've given up on like like I
usually get about uh a thousand to two
thousand messages a day just generally
like including DMS emails everything
because I'm on my newsletter and all
this stuff it when I open up Instagram
in the morning it just keeps refreshing
like over and over in my DMs
[Music]
ramit what's going on man we're live
what's up Sam for me from how to teach I
will I will teach how to teach what am I
saying why can't I think of the name of
your is this your intro you're giving me
you don't even know the name of my
company you better try that again I will
teach you to be rich you know why I
confuse it all times because one of my
favorite books of all time is Felix
Dennis's uh
and I always confuse you YouTube his is
how to get rich well right well you want
to know something even more confusing my
new Netflix show is now called how to
get rich
dude what's going on
what's up so you just had a show come
out two days ago or three days ago right
yep
how's it been are you like have you
noticed that like the revenue of your
business or the podcast downloads that
you have are they going up uh the
reception is like out of control like
I'll I'll give you the numbers but like
I thought I thought shows great I did
not expect for it to be top 10 on
Netflix
um the number of emails I've gotten I
just gave up on even being able to be on
top of my DMs it's just wild podcast
numbers
um right now the podcast is number 12 on
all of Apple
um I'm very proud to say we have
displaced Ben Shapiro so you know one
bigot at a time we're gonna take it down
and uh
um number of social media followers is
fantastic just like the best part of all
is people are posting pictures from
their family rooms all over the world
and it's like you can tell a lot by
seeing
a family room you know you can tell just
a ton about someone's life and then you
see the same show in every one of those
photos it's it's kind of like Cosmic
it's like humanity is all watching the
same thing which is pretty cool you uh
what percentage increase of uh downloads
per episode has your pod gone from that
well it hasn't even been out a week so I
can't even tell you yet but well you
could look at your current your current
numbers can't you of the podcast I don't
know I guess I'm not as sophisticated as
you yeah yeah I mean I would have
thought that you know how to log into
things but yeah I understand I I guess I
overestimated your ability uh what
wasn't I can only be good at a couple of
things and then the rest I'm pretty
deficient at them so I've known you were
meat for a while now and I've been
following you for it feels like a decade
I don't remember what year you started
doing it but it feels like you've been I
mean you've been you were like one of
the OG bloggers so like basically I
started about 20 years ago oh it was 20
years ago wow so basically I know my
best friend is Neville I met him because
I was a fan of his blog and I found his
blog because of Noah kagan's blog I
found Noah kagan's blog because of
probably like Tim Ferriss and then I
probably found Tim Ferriss because of
you it was like this Illuminati of like
businessy Financial bloggers but a
little bit lifestyle and you've been
doing that you're like the OG I remember
you like would teach classes like you
wrote a blog post you would like you
hung up flyers on the Stanford campus
you're like I'm gonna do uh uh personal
finance class or something like that and
then that kind of like parlayed into one
thing which led to another thing now
you've got this pretty big business I've
talked to a lot of people who work for
you it's a pretty like amazing company
that you built then you came out with
podcast and you told me you're going to
come out the podcast and I was like okay
this sounds interesting you're a little
late to the game you've been doing this
for 20 years
let's see your podcast is actually
amazing you did something that I've
always wanted to do but I didn't think
people would do it so basically you
could explain it but you like tell or
people tell you all of their finances
and they put their faces on the videos
so like it's not really Anonymous then
you parlayed that into you've had a you
know all these books along the way
you've parlayed that into just a brand
new Netflix show that's now one of the
most popular in the country I mean
you've done a lot of stuff right uh I
love your intro it's like better than
any intro I can give myself so thank you
it sounds so linear the way you say it
like I sat at a chess board and just
like mapped it out but if you go into
the the details of it like it's actually
crazy for example yeah I did hang up
flyers and I did try to get my friends
in the dining halls in college to come
to my free event and nobody came for
like a year and a half nobody would come
to my events like I would struggle to
get people to come to get a free class
on money
and I you know I got like a handful of
people over a year and a half and the
reason for that I later learned is that
people don't really like going to events
about money it makes them feel bad about
themselves and so I was like okay you
know when you're young and you're like
really hungry you go this isn't working
like the world needs to hear what I have
to say and so like you can either give
up and sometimes you should
or in my case I was like these kids are
so lazy they don't even want to come to
a free class I'm just going to start a
blog and so that that's the path it
wasn't like flyers and then Netflix show
there's like a lot of
um trying and failing in between the two
but so you're only in your 20s when
you're teaching that I mean what the
hell did you know about money
um I had gotten pretty good at money
actually so I started uh my dad uh you
know came from India as my mom did and
my dad it's pretty pretty actually Savvy
with money he got me to open up a Roth
IRA when I was like 14 15 years old he
helped me do it with a custodial account
and I took my scholarship money which I
got for college that first check and I
put in the stock market and I thought it
was a genius 1999 everybody's so cool
and uh I lost half of that pretty fast
um funny enough though I kept investing
because I was working at a pizza place I
was doing some sales thing and so I was
investing
I used to think investing meant picking
stocks so I bought three stocks when I
was in high school one of them
excite at home bankrupt another one jdsu
why the hell was I buying telecom stocks
I don't know bankrupt and then a third
stock of a little company called
amazon.com
which I've held since then and it's like
awesome now the lesson for that
everybody listening everyone goes oh
that's so cool ramit so cool I just got
to pick the next Amazon and Sam and I go
no you don't you're never gonna pick the
next Amazon that was complete luck do
not do that strategy and the real the
real lesson there is don't try to pick
individual stocks pick a nice Target
date fund or index fund and then let it
ride and you will have more money than
you know what to do with of course
that's you and me if Sean were here he
would be telling us about some crypto
[__] that we talked about last time
which of course went down by 65 and
before we continue I'd just like to give
a big shout out to all the people on
YouTube from the last episode we did who
they didn't like me very much you know
they're the crypto guys you saw the
comment I [__] read every comment
dude I love it and they go this guy's
such an old fuddy duddy and what I
really want to do Sam is come on here
and and let's go to the comment section
and just see
what happened to all these folks who
lost 60 of their money I wonder if
they're I wonder if they think the same
thing yeah anyway it was a fun episode
last time we uh did I don't know if you
heard the episode I always give Sean a
hard time because his opinion in my
opinion on investing are totally
opposites but not totally opposites but
we agree uh we disagreeing a lot but on
the pot I was going Sean so look if I
made a bet with you or like if I was a
genie and I said you can only you can
start your own company and invest your
own money in your own company
but you can't buy crypto you can't
invest in startups you can't do any like
cash flowing things you can't do
anything all you could do is put it into
this one thing we'll call it an index
fund but whatever it is and you get a
regular return of eight percent a year
now it's regular it's not you know the
theoretical
bit is that it's eight percent but it's
right it's lumpy but let's just say
eight percent every single year but you
can't you can't invest in anything else
other than your business would you do
that and he was like 100 absolutely not
and in my head I'm like dude that's like
the greatest thing on Earth what are you
talking about that's the greatest thing
okay
I heard that episode I was laughing so
hard I loved it actually it's fun to
hear two people with totally different
opinions I I will say although I'm like
you I'm a huge fan of index funds and
average returns of seven to eight
percent are actually phenomenal if you
understand compound interest and time
that is a lot of money does eight
percent double in nine years
approximately so 72 divided by your
return rate if we say 10 nominal it's
about every seven to ten years it
doubles so yeah you're right in the
range and that doesn't sound like a lot
if you're putting in like a thousand
dollars two thousand dollars but what
people forget is that you don't just put
money in once you keep contributing so
it's like you've got a A Train That's
going faster and faster and you're
pushing the train it starts to go really
and at a certain point you can't stop
the train it's humongous so um anyway I
love hearing the back and forth I
personally was 100 with you I'm like
eight percent all day baby I love
average returns that's fantastic but you
know some people they think differently
or they get a thrill from investing I
don't get a thrill from investing I get
a thrill from staying in luxury hotels
that's what I love but my investing is
very boring well so my money right now I
basically have um you know I sold my
company to HubSpot stock and a lot of
that was HubSpot stock how much did you
sell it for Sam you're gonna tell us uh
no uh I I don't like about it Sam's so
transparent with every other number on
this show except for how much money is
in his bank account Sam what's up with
that the reported number was 27 million
and uh you know it was more or less it
was it was right around there but here's
the thing is that no I'm gonna I'll
reveal it a little bit here's the thing
which is the sale I received a whole
bunch of HubSpot stock and six months or
you guys can I think we sold February of
two years ago so you guys can go look at
it I think the stock was 367 when we
sold and then over the next year as a
bunch of my stock was like you know I
got it monthly or quarterly or something
like that as I was getting it
it almost tripled so or doubled and a
half so it went up from 367 I think to
870 and so the price like kind of
materially changed of course then it
went back down to like 300 and now it's
back up but um so the the price
materially changed because of that but
here's the deal so I own HubSpot stocks
I haven't sold a share I didn't sell it
when it was at its peak I was like I'm
just never gonna log in and look at it
we own Airbnb stock because my wife
worked there and or works there and we
we got a bunch of that and then besides
that I just own like the normal 80 20 uh
whatever I don't even know what what
it's called the normal Vanguard index
fund and then like some type of like you
know bonds whatever's the the normal
bonds besides that
it then there's a little bit of real
estate uh but besides that it's like
nothing I don't really own any I've
never actually sold the stock in my life
um that's awesome that's awesome
I think it's awesome so many of my
friends mocked me it is awesome no no no
no they don't know what they're talking
about they see they get the thrill out
of tweaking their asset allocation and I
go listen if it's a thrill to you great
but if they actually understood how much
it truly cost them they would be shocked
you actually deeply understand personal
finance so you know that kind of like
making turkey dinner for Thanksgiving
once you put in the oven you let that
thing cook do not fiddle around with it
you're just messing it up but it's
really hard even for super smart people
especially entrepreneurs who love
control they really feel the need to
fiddle around and it's so
counterproductive with investing so you
said something I totally agree with you
you said something awesome on your show
which is people confuse I forget how you
phrased it but you said something about
making money versus managing money and
when I first started making money I was
like oh great now I now I'm very
confident I feel like I'm pretty good at
making money I'm in the 99 percentile of
income like making income
and then I was like well that's pretty
easy I could do this real estate thing
and I can do this deal and this thing
and then I started getting into it and
I'm like
[__] I'm not great at that because
I'm creative and I can invent things
from scratch but when it comes to
investing that's not always it's more
about like due diligence and about uh
like uh uh running Financial like for a
real estate company oftentimes is more
close to just being really good at Excel
than it is like you know inventing
something from scratch and you said that
on the show the other day when I was
watching and I I thought that was like
amazing and I didn't actually learn that
until I made a few expensive mistakes of
managing versus making oh that's cool
yeah that's totally true and I think
there's three there's making managing
and spending all three very distinct
skills and everybody primarily focuses
on the first making money I understand
why people want to make more money the
managing money feels very dry and
therefore people are incentivized and
driven to make it sexy and mess up and
do things and then spending no one
really consciously thinks about you know
I always say people everybody teaches us
how to save nobody teaches us how to
spend meaningfully so those three models
would be good if anyone's really
thinking about how to live a rich life
specifically around their money it's
like think about those three models and
think about what it would take to be
really good for each
I don't I'm not good at the spending
thing and like there's been multiple
times where I've called you and I'm like
I'm gonna go to Europe and you go oh
I'll I'll tell you what to do but only
one rule no budget or I'll be like I
want to dress better and you say great I
have a list of cool stores one rule no
budget and yeah you're pretty dogmatic
on a handful of things and you're
someone to you to you I wouldn't say
that to a school teacher I say to a rich
dude who sold his company for a lot of
money so I go listen if you're gonna be
if you're gonna be looking at the price
tags and and you're going to be looking
through the money lens of cost imagine
you put on a pair of glasses and it's
cost I go I'm not doing that with you
you're too rich you can't be looking at
Cost there are other money lenses for a
guy like you to use which is totally
appropriate but when did you feel
comfortable spending
late 20s I started to make it a practice
to get good I'll give you an example
because Fitness we both love Fitness
dude I follow all your videos I'm like
this guy what are you doing the combine
or something that was hilarious so Sam
Sam's posting all this like insane stuff
he's doing like 60 inch vertical jump or
whatever it it's like crazy your squats
are like out of this world I'm like God
this guy how does he do it anyway you
know I had to have a little fun with Sam
so I go hey Sam nice uh 375 squat watch
you try practicing for a spelling bee
[Laughter]
I called you a douche and everyone
thought we were actually angry at each
other yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so but
but you've always been comfortable I
mean like dude I just feel guilty buying
a two thousand dollar like jacket and
also it doesn't necessarily bring me joy
which is a whole other thing but I also
definitely feel a sense now yeah that's
like I think value uh that's viable or
that's a valid thing but I don't I don't
I feel guilty you don't have guilt
around somebody's spending no never
let's talk about why so when I was in my
late 20s I was like okay I want to learn
how to get fit I never knew about
Fitness when I was young we didn't even
use the word protein in my house like we
it was not a thing really yeah no like
that's if you told my my parents that a
Coca-Cola has 40 grams of sugar they'd
be like you might as well tell me
there's a billion grams because I don't
know what that means you know what I
mean like that means yeah okay so same
so so now I'm like really confused
because I'm like how does Sam look so
good if he didn't even like protein I
learned like what age uh well I was a
college athlete but and so I knew about
Fitness and then once I started uh once
I left college and got fat uh then I
married a woman who like cared about
this stuff and she kind of like taught
me she's like hey you know just because
it says low fat that doesn't mean that
that's good for you and I was like oh it
true or okay that's why men live longer
yeah I was like the Sleep gym is me like
it's good for you this is keto right
like I didn't know you know what I mean
it's like yogurt is yogurt therefore
it's good totally okay so when I I
didn't even like I didn't have the
college athlete thing I did you know I
did well in school or whatever but
um when I when I graduated I said I
wanna start like getting fit and it was
like my mid-20s I had a friend at work I
was like dude can you show me how to
like work out so I was pretty skinny I
was a really skinny guy and you hear
clues in the world whether it's with
work or with Fitness or whatever the
world gives you Clues as to where you
stand and that can be true even in
meetings like if somebody shows up five
minutes late repeatedly that's a clue
maybe you're lower on the power totem
pole and you've kind of got to learn to
read the clues to know where you stand
and I remember multiple people when I
was in college calling me skinny now as
a guy that's actually not a good thing
to be called at least I didn't like it
and so I just thought I'm genetically
skinny you know that's just how I am
skinny Indian guy ha ha ha
but I didn't want to do it anymore and
so a friend of mine showed me how to
work out and he was like okay do you
like to eat
um like spaghetti I was like yeah he's
like do you like bread I was like yeah
he's like do you like milk I was like
okay he goes hmm yeah you need to eat
all of that and I was like huh and that
that was just like oh what I thought I
was doing was actually not getting me
the goals I wanted so I started to eat
more I actually started to track it and
I realized what I thought I was eating
was totally off base just common for all
of us
um but it took me until my late 20s when
I moved to New York and I get there and
like everyone looks great yeah just
everybody looks good fashion wise
Fitness I'm like did everyone attend a
class that I was absent for how the hell
does everybody know how to hem their
pants correctly and so I lived right by
a gym it took me four months to get the
courage to walk into that gym
and say I want a personal trainer it had
nothing to do with money I had money but
I knew that once I said that I would
actually have to follow through and so I
finally got the courage four months I
walk across the street go in the gym
pick this guy the random trainer who
happened to be walking by he was
actually great strength trainer and I
ended up training with him for about
five years and I learned so much before
I switched over to bodybuilding and
training a little different but that
that was like starting to pay for value
and I realized oh my God they're you can
get better results you can get faster
results sometimes if you pay for a
different restaurant you get a better
experience and that was important to me
while at the same time there are other
things I just don't care about and I
don't pay for it at all on the show
there was there's this couple they're
like maybe only 38 or 39 they're but
there are grandparents I forget their
names
um yeah Monique and Donnell yeah and I
and they're very likable but I got so
angry watching them because
on the show
they you sit and I I hate this
experience that what you what you did
with these people because it happens to
me sometimes they sat down and they
expressed everything they want in life
or at least everything they want help
from and they say we struggle with this
and you say all right here's the plan
does everyone agree to the plan and they
go yes we totally agree to this plan
this will help us get to where we want
to go that plan includes selling a whole
bunch of stuff from a storage unit it
includes not spending a certain amount
of money and so not buying I think he
was spending 500 or 600 a month on video
games or something crazy and then you
fast forward two weeks later and he
orders this big box and they open the
box and there's literally like eight
pairs of jeans and like a hundred and
twenty dollar pair of shoes and you're
like what the hell man we you said you
wanted this and we agreed that the
actions are this and and then he tries
to like justify he goes but I need these
jeans and there's literally eight pairs
of them then there's this other woman
who has this 1.1 million dollar house
she goes I'm I'm you know my kids are
grown now I don't need this huge house
I'm gonna sell it and get a smaller
house just because I don't want to take
care of this fast forward a few weeks
later she sold the house she went and
bought a 2.2 million dollar house that's
even bigger and she goes yeah but I need
this and yeah it pissed me off so much
that these people were doing this and I
was like
what the hell guys where's the
discipline in this and I think that
that's like a huge difference between
like some people and other people that
like achieve certain things I just want
to like nail it in their heads like you
guys you realize how like you're you're
a hypocrite to yourself right now uh you
know what I mean uh well I so I'll tell
you you know when I was in my early 20s
starting with my you know showing people
how to invest and stuff I was super
judgmental like super and it's like oh
my God like you need to open up a Roth
IRA do you understand how seven percent
compounds and I could actually see
people's eyes
glaze over I could basically see their
soul leave their body I'm just like oh
this isn't connecting but I didn't know
how to read the clues I thought if I
push him harder if I show them another
chart they'll get it
um and I can tell you that that doesn't
work and so when you're saying that you
hated this I'm actually smiling because
I kind of love that I love when people
say one thing and do another because to
me it's like that beautiful
contradiction of humanity all of us say
we want something and we do something
different
and to me it's like a puzzle okay I know
that you're doing that in the domain of
money I totally get it I've seen it a
million times so how can I figure out a
way to reach you which gets you to see
the contradiction and change your
behavior not me to impose it on you
totally different View and I think much
more effective that's what you see on
the show
yeah well you're a patient and like it
just but it's still it angered me
because I liked them they're very
likable and you want them to win it's
like ramit show it's kind of like Queer
Eye For The Straight Guy but for like
money like you like root for like it's
like oh we're going from uh Zero to Hero
or like we're taking like someone who's
like you know cute but you know we take
the glasses off and all of a sudden
she's a model you know what I mean it's
like like a like a high school movie but
like you root for them but I'm like you
guys this is so obvious these mistakes
that you're making it's angering me this
is gonna make you not achieve what you
want to achieve and that like irked me
so much watching that not Earth but it
frustrated me well I like that I like I
want you and I want all the millions of
people watching it to feel something and
that that alone is a win because money
we don't usually feel anything except
overwhelm and shame so I like that
you're watching this and going God it's
so obvious now I will say you have built
discipline over like decades yeah you
have been practicing at it right for a
long time some of us don't even grow up
with discipline in our lives like I grew
up with discipline around reading a
spelling book literally for two and a
half hours a day I I could do that and I
did very well at that but the discipline
to be empathetic I didn't really grow up
with that I was like a utilitarian type
of guy so I think that it's fun to watch
them at like it's fun to watch people
have to find their own path to get where
they're going and you know what people
are people some people do it some people
don't that's kind of the beauty of
humanity not everyone is going to
succeed and that's that's how it goes
the other interesting thing was the same
couple that I'm referring to they had
this so these folks I think their annual
and their household income maybe was 90
grand a year and this woman about that
this woman quit her job to this
woodworking thing which is awesome but
they had this storage unit that I think
cost 400 a month and we open up the
storage unit and it's sorry folks if
you're listening it's garbage it was
like an old used microwave it was like
plastic like toys and like containers
from Target like it was just junk like
the amount at which they probably spent
in two months was worth more than the
entire stuff and it was like
dude why aren't you selling this
microwave and he goes well I need it and
it that and that also bothered me
because
dude Americans have so much crap this
this couple I think is very is very
normal is very average and I was shocked
at how much stuff people have and it
made me want to go through my closet and
just get rid of everything I'm like dude
we don't need any of his junk not only
does it not make you happy it brings you
down it was just so much stuff was that
normal that you said people with so much
stuff
yeah okay so I had never gone into
people's houses until a few years ago
with my business and I had had offers
from producers and stuff to go into
someone's house but it was always this
sort of like go into this couple's house
and then like finger wag at them and
tell them all the things they're doing
wrong it's just not my vibe I don't want
to do that I'd actually ask him like
what do you love spending on let's go do
more of that come on you want a nice bag
cool let me show you how to get more and
finally there was a producer who is a
friend of mine and she said like come on
you really got to come out this one's
special so they drove me to New Jersey
and I went into this young woman's
apartment it was a new apartment complex
very nice he had a Jeep outside
and the minute she opened the door
I thought to myself I should have done
this 10 years ago
because
you can tell so much by going into the
entryway of someone's house okay at the
time I was living in Manhattan most of
my friends had somewhat similar
Apartments to me we kind of live in a
similar way
when I walked into her apartment there
were beautiful candles like nice
diptyque style Candles there were
probably 15 or 20 of them those are very
expensive
so I'm taking it in okay cool she loves
Candles there was a gigantic TV okay
that's pretty interesting uh and I asked
her to pull up on her phone and read off
the top 10 emails in her inbox it was
like Target Pier One you know whatever
stores
this starts to tell you a lot about
someone it's basically Clues and like
you may see a living room I see how much
percentage of her net income is going to
fix costs and I'm able to start to
figure out what's really going on with
her
um with folks like on the show you can
totally see the amount of stuff people
have and after a while that stuff starts
to control them when I ask people like
what's your rich life almost nobody says
a bunch of ten dollar items from Target
I can guarantee that they might say I
love a beautiful sweater I love trips
with my kids Etc I go cool let's spend
more on that and let's cut back on the
stuff that you don't care about and that
really resonates with people yeah it's
just like I I've grew up in Missouri I
grew up with in a very normal household
all my friends growing up are normal and
then I go back and I look at like how I
grew up and where my friend like oh my
God like my parents have a stereo
that still has a cassette tape player
like and I don't think they've turned
this on in 15 years and it's like I'm
like hey Mom and Dad you should throw
that away it doesn't even work and they
go oh but you know we're gonna I'm like
you guys you don't have a tape you don't
even have a cassette yeah play anything
this is a great
it's a great lesson is we have to be
very very conscious of the things we buy
because once they come into our home and
once they become part of our identity it
is almost impossible to get rid of them
and everyone listening is like oh yeah
those those people why don't they just
get rid of and I'm going just look in
your closet you know my wife is a
personal stylist she goes in people's
closets she helps them do closet
cleanses she does all their image and
stuff like that she will show me how
many trash bags she fills with clothes
to be donated sometimes it's a small
closet six trash bags one client I think
40 bags that were taken out and donated
it is really hard to get rid of stuff
that's why I you know for me I go I'm
gonna be super careful about what I
bring into my house clothes Electronics
whatever when I get it I want it to be
the best and then when I get the best I
want to keep it for a long period of
time like you don't have to do the same
but I would say develop your philosophy
as to what you're gonna buy and how long
you're gonna to keep it for otherwise
you're just going to end up inundated
with a bunch of junk we had um Neil
Patel in the Pod and he like people got
so angry at him because he goes I spend
I think he said he spends 200 000 a
month in monthly expenses and he broke
that down and then we had another person
come on and do the same thing I think um
I think I spend me personally I think I
don't have a kid
um I think we spend 20 to 30 000 a month
and I remember like when I was
22 starting my company I spent two grand
a month including a rat like nothing and
I remember thinking like if 20 grand a
month I I can't even I can't even
imagine what I would spend with 20 grand
a month now that I spend 20 or 30 a
month I think oh yeah I could make a
dent with 100 Grand a month like that I
could I I could I could use that
anything above that I actually think
it's challenging but maybe I'll find my
way one day how much do you think you
spend a month and have you found
thresholds of like
this doesn't feel any better than this
lower number
oh this is a great question
um
well I think that
thresholds are to me less interesting
than what are the things that I love to
spend a lot of money on and what are the
things I don't care about and I'm like
extremely polarized and I actually want
everyone to be polarized so for me the
worst is if people go I spend a little
bit here I spend a little bit there or I
try to cut back five percent here and
five percent there I'm just like that
sucks that's not an effective strategy
and it's not even fun so you said this
concept of you you say don't do five
dollar problems do thirty thousand
dollar problems I think is that right
don't ask three dollar questions ask
thirty thousand dollar questions and
people go like what are you talking
about I go let me explain most people
agonize over coffee and can I get an
extra dessert and I go that's irrelevant
if you want to buy a coffee or two go
ahead that makes no material effect on
your finances over the long term but
thirty thousand dollar questions are
things like what's my savings rate for
example do I save and invest uh 12 per
year okay great what if my partner and I
make a agreement every year we're going
to increase that number by one percent
if you just made that decision alone
that's worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars okay more than all the coffee
you'll ever buy in your life combined
what's my asset allocation that's a 300
000 question uh what is my debt payoff
date if you have debt I guarantee you do
not know the exact month and year you're
going to pay it off you should know that
so for my spending I love talking about
this because I always encourage people
to to come up with their money dial what
is the thing you love spending on should
we just do this right now yeah yeah
let's do this with you Sam okay what is
your what what do you love spending on
what's the one thing uh flying first
class uh so when I when I fly when I fly
I like to if it's above three hours I
it's first class uh I don't care I love
it I don't I don't like fancy hotels but
I like nice airbnbs because I like
Apartments over like a smaller uh Hotel
uh I like spending on
um like when I like to go out to eat I
love leaving huge tips so if it's a good
service I like doing like 100 tips love
it I like toys So like um four-wheelers
and motorcycles I love Action Sports and
things like that what else do I like and
I like service you got your gym yeah I
got my gym so yeah so a gym would be
somewhat like a toy but I love services
so I spend 400 a month for a trainer I
spend another 600 a month for like a
doctor who I can just ask uh like or
sorry nutritionist so I can ask
questions uh do a nutritionist uh
cleaners someone to come and cook I love
services and like an assistant someone
who'll uh do my laundry like all types
of services but not too many uh things
love it okay great so I think for
everyone listening
let's let's highlight a couple things on
that first question play along with us
so what is the thing you love spending
money on most people's answer is eating
out that's the number one money dial
number two is travel number three is
health and wellness number four is
convenience you basically have like all
of those but that makes a lot of sense
you've been very successful financially
so you've added money dials most people
start with eating out okay fine
pick one of your money dials which you
would say is the one that gets you super
pumped super excited services so
convenience great love it I'm the same
convenience is my money dial I love it
I'm obsessed with it people think like
I'm a serial killer when they hear how I
dial all my stuff in but like I don't
care that's what I love okay here's the
question number two if you were to
quadruple the amount you spent on that
money dial
what would your life look like and feel
like
uh I think it would actually be awesome
so like for example right now I have a
service that does my laundry and brings
it to my door and then I have uh this
wonderful woman who cleans my house but
she doesn't put my laundry away and so
what I would love to do is just say hey
I'll pay you more money just make sure
that my closet is always organized and
my clothes are put away because my
clothes will just leave stay like nicely
folded on the floor in my closet so
small things like that or or uh uh like
if my dog goes to the bathroom outside
like I sometimes I'll forget to clean it
up and then I'll realize there's a bunch
of it I'm like oh I gotta go clean it up
it's nice to have someone to come and
just handle all of that so someone just
to handle all types of cleaning and uh
organizing my house I would love that
okay I think I like your answers but I
think you got to dream a little bigger
you could get all that with like 100
bucks a week
everybody everybody look at Sam's face
he's like lost right now go ahead I'm
gonna take you with me on this I think
I'm quite bad at like dreaming big
yes that's why I'm here
all right so I'd say what do we do now
what else would you do I said quadruple
not at a hundred dollars a week
um I would have an assistant come to my
home twice a week and we would go
through my to-do list
love it what else
think about traveling think about
cleaning your car think about uh how you
uh travel with your family
um it would be awesome to fly private
occasionally with my whole nucleus fan
my nuclear family
and who would coordinate all of that
right now me
well not in this quadruple scenario I'm
going to say Amanda me and my family
want to go from St Louis to New York
around this date hook it up there's
gonna be eight of us just tell me when
to show up or have a car there
love it love it and then um you
mentioned that you love tipping which I
love too I am a huge fan of huge tips
I've told people like part of your rich
life very likely should be generosity
how would that fit in like the person
who cleans your house what might you do
in terms of spending more there
um I would probably so like over
Christmas I gave her a 200 bonus
um I think it would have been cool to
say here's a thousand dollars just
thanks there you go all right love it
this is awesome okay so for again for
everybody listening the question is you
already identified your money dial the
thing you love now what if you could
quadruple your spending now I'll tell
you what I loved about Sam's answer and
then I'll tell you what was different
about Sam's answer than most people's
answer so Sam was immediately like oh he
knew exactly what he would do he's like
my clothes sit on the floor of my closet
which by the way is barbaric Sam that's
so he goes I'm gonna get someone to hang
them up okay great by the way I love
that all I feel like most of my friends
my closest friends are Indians the
Indians I don't friends with like
Neville they're always Immaculate
there's never clubs of course there's
never clutter oh yeah well yeah and they
their clothes are yeah well it's that
thank you for saying that Immaculate I
love that I'll take that the immaculate
I was just at Neville's house today and
I'm like Neville you never have clutter
you just it's always everything's
perfect
wow Neville my man okay he's gonna be so
happy to hear this man it's like two
people talking about you behind your
back and actually saying nice things no
he's Immaculate that's the best okay
what is different about Sam's answer
than most people is that you know he's
talking about fairly expensive things
right private jet Etc now don't let that
turn you off I'll tell you what the most
common answer I get is I told you that
people go eating out and I go okay if
you could quadruple your spend which is
why I call it a money dial you could
turn that dial up like a cereal what
would it look like and most people have
the same linear answer they go well I'd
probably have to go on a diet because
I'd be eating out four times a week and
I go and then I go Hey listen would you
still eat at Chipotle
and they're like they stop for a second
and they go oh probably not it's a human
tendency that we just take what we're
doing and we do it times four same thing
but linear and I want to stop them I
want to dimensionalize it I go would you
still eat at Chipotle they go no
I go where would you eat and now they're
thinking there's a guy in DC he goes I
have a list of every michelin-starred
restaurant I go who would you take with
you
and he gets very quiet he goes I take my
family because they can't afford to eat
at places like that and so when you're
thinking about your rich life it's so
important to understand where you are
today what's important to you and if you
can spend extravagantly on that thing
what does it look like feel like smell
like taste like because you need that
crisp Vision otherwise what are you
working for why are you going to invest
and save and once you have that Vision I
want to take my family to New York I
want us to go to Central Park and all
have a picnic there and you can see what
you're going to eat and what you're
gonna do and it's just like so beautiful
it smells fresh in the fall that's when
it becomes much easier for me to say
okay we know you want to spend
extravagantly on that now show me what
you want to cut costs mercilessly on so
that is the way that we start to craft a
rich life
what does your you know your the phrase
like everyone thinks or a lot of people
I imagine see I will teach you to be
rich and they think this guy's a douche
and then whenever you change it and you
say wait hold on I've never I've never
heard anyone say that that's actually
well I'm just kidding
yeah they go they go yeah
the number one way people introduce me
on Reddit is they go hey uh you should
read this guy's book it's called I will
teach bridge I know it sounds like a
huge scam but it's actually not and I
you know it's been 20 years or whatever
10 years I go all right fine I accept it
well you come up with this good line
that is 100 redeems yourself which is
it's about living like what's your rich
life which is totally great because
you're like no it's money's a component
but like your rich life could be
anything and so that's actually quite
redeeming your rich life you said is
like convenience so what is your like I
don't know how do we say this without
sounding lame your convenient stack like
what is your what is your like okay
what's that look like and what's and
what's your budget for that
I have an unlimited budget companies
that are important to me quit yanking my
leg quit being academic how much do you
spend a month for like this amazing
setup
well I don't first of all I don't think
on a monthly basis so you know I don't
want anyone to be thinking on a monthly
basis except for your conscious spending
plan so in order to have a bigger
perspective you think on an annual
perspective minimum so for me I would
spend uh uh well if I factor it all in
probably
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
year on convenience so it's 300 take it
down for you it's 300 000 or the right
number or is it on the upper side of
that it's hard to say let me give you an
example like if I stay at an amazing
hotel which I love would that be part of
convenience it's quite pricey or would
it be part of like luxury or experience
I don't know but I'll tell you like the
big components of it so I want to wake
up in the morning
and I want every single thing in its
place so much so that if I go blind I
know exactly where everything is so that
means
my food is ready that means that my
calendar invitations have the link in
the same place which takes me to the
exact same thing it's all convenience my
meetings are scheduled
um when I travel I have an assistant
who's amazing
um when I travel
to a W-2 employee or or okay W-2
um a very experienced seasoned executive
assistant who knows how to work with
other Executives who knows how to work
with everybody in my life
um so she would be responsible for
everything from day-to-day meetings
scheduling haircuts
um complex uh travel planning
interacting with a travel advisor things
like that and she knows my preferences
so we documented all she knows if I'm
flying a four-hour flight this is the
type of seat this is the exact seat I'm
going to sit on and what I love about
having an assistant is they become your
basically your spokesperson or your
right hand person and so they have to be
able to interact with people at CEO
levels and at every level
um so that that's super important for me
um when we when I travel I have a travel
protocol it gets activated so it means
like
she will handle my email a little
differently if I go if I'm going
somewhere I'll have food sent ahead to
the hotel if I'm staying in certain
locations so it's like healthy food I
can try to stay on plan as much as
possible uh things like that so we over
time we just document it and it just
becomes like part of an sop didn't you
have like a program on like working with
someone uh like yeah I still have it
it's called delegate and done and this
is like how to hire an assistant like
the 35 Plus things that my assistant
does and actually how to run our
meetings like exactly how we run our
weekly check-in meetings
um yeah we have all that stuff all
templates it's awesome I'm gonna buy
this this is good
all right
what else we'll give you a link for the
show notes but that's for people who are
like I want assist a smoothie running
system I want an assistant who's smart
I'm not looking for the cheapest I'm
looking for the best and I want to
empower them to be able to handle
everything for me that that's awesome
what else
um uh what else is there um oh training
so I have a personal trainer
um he's awesome and like I go there and
train with him we have goals for the
show for example I knew exactly what I
wanted to look like and um it was funny
because I went in to get fitted for some
clothes my wife was styling me and I
went in and I was like okay this is the
size I'm gonna be and I was way bigger
than that size at that time were you
were either flat or muscle
uh a little of both I was bulking so I
was more muscle but I still had put on
some fat and I knew I was gonna start
cutting
um and they were like trying to be very
polite to me but they were like
um we would recommend you don't go uh
like that small and I was like listen
I'm a professional and I know exactly
what I'm gonna and they were like trying
to be really polite about it but I could
see them exchanging glances with each
other I was dying I was loving it
because you know everyone says that like
when you're going in for a wedding
fitting or whatever you're like yeah I'm
gonna lose like 15 pounds and like no
one does so they're like of course I'm
not telling you to lose weight but step
on the scale and subtract 15 and just be
that yeah
yo I was laughing so hard because my
wife we've like we've trained and like
we know what you know kind of what we
trained for our wedding for example so
we know the process and
I was very confident my trainer is
awesome
Etc and so
um I went back in for the the first
fitting nobody believed me I was like
just do what I said please and then I
came in for the next fitting and I
wanted to play a trick on him so I was
like from the fitting room I was like oh
my God this doesn't fit at all
but it actually like everything fit
perfectly and so that is an example
where like getting help right for
convenience for what's the look what's
the training protocol that kind of stuff
is is important
was it uh what's filming the show what
you thought it was going to be I mean
what's Sean's always wanted to have a
Netflix show uh what I mean what what do
people oh I should talk to him about it
yeah
um okay so I have filmed before like in
in a studio with my crew things like
that this was completely different like
it was on a whole nother level so I'll
give you some examples
um the week before the show started
filming
they finally found an office in La
literally one seven days before and they
designed it and they were like come on
in and walk through it and give us your
feedback on the design so first of all
they designed it in 24 hours that means
they took a blank
office and put a full design in there so
I walked in and I was like uh it looks
like a white person is selling their
Airbnb like it has like all geometric
shapes on the like wood I'm like no it's
not me like a live laugh love sign like
a neon sign yes exactly I was like uh
simplified so then
yeah uh yeah exactly work and I was like
we're not doing this no not for a in
Netflix show so then they were like oh
well do you have any suggestions for us
of course I had a Pinterest board of
like interior design home offices that I
pulled out and my style is wood Stone
Japanese design minimalism and basically
like an unlimited budget and they took
one look at that and they just started
laughing because they're like dude what
are you talking about we have a budget
and we have like two days to finish this
office so anyway we hashed it out we
came up with something that I think
looks pretty good
and when I went in the first day
the crew when I'm shooting just in an
office which is a totally controlled
environment there could have been like
30 people
that is huge multiple cameras sound
producers makeup it's embarrassing uh
uh like having a yeah it's like it's
like a performing it's like you're
acting really not just like shoot the
[__] or not shoot the [__] you know
whatever you do when you normally record
you're like having a conversation with
someone dude if 30 people around me I
would be like dude I feel like a like an
animal in the zoo
yeah well it's funny you say that I like
day to day doing like what we're doing
right now I love it I feel really
comfortable chatting with you or doing
an Instagram thing but being in the
Limelight especially in public or for
things like my birthday I have never
felt comfortable I like I actually dread
it and even for for my four yeah for my
40th birthday I was dragging my feet
like dragging it even though it's like
rich life and like I always love
bringing my friends and family together
and my wife noticed this and she's like
like what is wrong with you and I go I
don't know I was so indecisive she goes
do you want me to just plant it for you
and when she said that was like the
magic words like yes please because this
one thing in my life I just feel so
uncomfortable doing and once she started
to do it like it all took off I was
thrilled
um so this show was like for the first
few days I felt a little uncomfortable
the other unexpected part was
um going to people's houses
okay
people open up their houses it's the
most intimate thing you can do in
America is to open up your home and talk
about money like most more Americans
would be comfortable talking about their
sex lives than their credit card debt
that's actually research and so to
really know how to make people feel
comfortable with a camera crew and
producers and all that that that took
some learning but overall I thought the
crew was amazing they really helped me
feel good and and kind of come into my
own do you get paid directly to do it or
are you hoping that like the is this
just marketing for everything else you
do
I get paid I get paid as
um Talent which is what they call
somebody who would be a host so
Hollywood term is talent and then I'm
also an EP or executive producer on the
show as well so that's great there is
yeah yeah
and will they fill you in on how many
people watched it or is Netflix I think
they're like notorious for not like
telling you stuff right
correct they they there are some uh
things that they release but they don't
typically share actual numbers
um I will say like the show came out it
was number nine on all of Netflix the
first day number six the next day and
like the reception has been insane like
way bigger than I ever thought like how
many how many messages are you getting
oh dude I've given up on like like I
usually get about uh a thousand to two
thousand messages a day just generally
like including DMS emails everything
because I'm on my newsletter and all
this stuff it when I open up Instagram
in the morning it just keeps refreshing
like over and over in my DMs and I'm
like what am I supposed to do with this
I don't even know you um
you uh
have been like on I've noticed on
Twitter we've been friends for a while
on Twitter you've become more polarizing
and I have a feeling that part of that
is on purpose is that true
like you mean polarizing because of
politics
yeah but also like for example I agree
with you for the home so like you and I
agree that buying a home you should do
it because you want it not because it's
a good investment because the numbers
show it's actually not a good investment
it could be a good investment but that's
mostly Lux every once in a while but do
it because you want to and at best
assume it's a great store of value but
it's not necessarily going to be like a
wonderful return you know uh but like
you'll tweet like look at this I think
you'll say like look at this [__] they
think X Y and Z one of these idiots
gonna believe this no no no hold on I do
not say that but I do not say that I
would never call someone you say that
about political stuff you say that about
political stuff sorry I I but but you
are harsh on the home buying thing and
you're also harsh on other topics you're
not harsh on uh that thing uh the home
buying thing but you're like you will
call people morons or mostly political
stuff I think but uh okay
I I guess I have something against
right-wing extremism so yeah I'm pretty
straightforward and direct about that
which is like I don't accept it and like
[__] that and if people and I talk about
raising taxes on the rich including me I
go yeah we should I should I pay
historically low taxes we should and
people are kind of shocked when they
hear a guy with money going oh I
actually enjoy paying my taxes I feel
really good about them and we should uh
actually raise taxes people like what
the hell they also feel shocked when
they hear a money Guy saying like buying
a house actually might not be the best
investment
so it's funny I will say like when I
talk about real estate I definitely mix
it up and sometimes people will go like
remit you're so negative about buying a
house and I go the fact that you think
my advice which is run the numbers on
the biggest purchase of your life is
negative tells you how far the Overton
window has shifted that if someone says
you should actually calculate the
biggest purchase of your life that's
being negative I go no no no no no no no
no you have to run the numbers and as
you and I know Sam a lot of times it's
like not that great of an investment
index funds could often not always but
often outperform more often so more
often
yeah depending on the city and like for
for everybody listening I lived in I've
rented for uh about 20 years I have made
more money renting than I would have
owning and I've rented in San Francisco
New York La in New York for example I
kept a very close eye on the real estate
market
it would have cost me 2.2 times more to
own the equivalent unit same
neighborhood same view same size same
number of bedrooms
2.2 times and so if it was a three
thousand dollar apartment it would have
cost like 62 6400 a month when you
factor in all the Phantom cost interest
opportunity cost maintenance I just took
the 3200 I just put in the market and
made way more money and less hassle but
your political thing that's like on your
list of things to do to stick out right
you have a list here of how to stand out
and you say unconditional unconventional
decisions Stand Out talk politics yes
talk about politics yes that's what I
mean let's talk about it yeah yeah so I
had this YouTube video I did many years
ago which was like why I don't talk
about politics I think it's still up on
YouTube and I was like hey guys I am
like uh you know I'm not gonna talk
about it and I had my reasons
and 2016 happened and I was like no way
no [__] way not in the country I grew
up in where we have comments like let's
ban Muslims until we figure out what's
going on I go what the [__] this is this
is crazy I stop and you know what I
studied in college right I studied
propaganda social influence and
persuasion Cults I studied that and I
start to see the same Dynamics happening
here I go if I can't speak up a first
generation successful guy who was lucky
and also worked hard became successful
you know in in the ways business and all
this stuff
if I can't do it then who can't and so I
started to do it and people flipped out
the first few posts I made were like
um stick to finance
I go first of all they always are the
same type of people who tell me this and
and they expect because of the way I
look they expect me to kind of roll over
and be like oh sorry you're right you're
right I come right back at him I go I'm
not going to stick to anything this is
my feed and I'll tell you exactly what's
going on by the way I happen to know a
little bit more about this than you and
they are shocked shy and I post their
comments to me it's quite uh
Illuminating when you see so over the
last like five six years I've actually
had like thousands of conversations
thousands of political conversations why
because I actually don't get the chance
to talk to people like this in real life
people who go like
um uh we should like cut all taxes taxes
are theft and then I go like tell me why
like what about the roads you drive on
who should do that and I I really get to
understand get inside their minds and
sometimes I post the conversations
because I want you to see a lot of
people go we should like we should
reason we should have conversations I go
take a look at these conversations like
I'm very patient with them but yeah I do
think that um people are afraid to talk
about their genuine Pol political
beliefs or to say like this is actually
wrong
um because they're worried about what's
going to happen to their business my
business is based on my reputation and I
go look if you're going to leave if if
you don't agree that young people should
have access to voting rights then don't
buy my book I'm totally fine with you
leaving my community and I believe that
but you have a list of other things on
here and some of the things I uh I
wanted to talk about so what's the DNS
list do not sell list and how does that
make you stand up oh so
well when you so let's the whole concept
of standing out is the world wants you
to be vanilla I saw that you start out
your business have you noticed I see I
say that line all the time on this yeah
I appreciate you saying it okay thank
you everyone make sure you hear that
credit no I give credit but you you that
line does the world wants you to be
vanilla I use that all the time and I'm
vanilla by the way I could say it
no I don't actually I don't think so
okay look vanilla means the world wants
you
to be like everybody else and it comes
out in Peculiar ways right the world
wants you to eat vanilla they go uh Sam
you're throwing money away on rent you
should buy a place vanilla and now for
some people buying a house makes perfect
sense but if you're 23 years old you
don't know where you're going to be in
three years it doesn't make any sense
um the world wants you to be vanilla
they tell me ramit you should stop
cursing on your
um YouTube videos I go but that's how I
talk and sometimes I hear stuff that's
crazy what do you want me to say you
want me to stop because of the algorithm
no I'm not living my life by an
algorithm
um the world wants you to be vanilla
when they told me ramit you shouldn't
sell programs that's scammy you should
give it all away for free I go no this
is a profitable business and I'm totally
comfortable charging thousands of
dollars for programs that are going to
change your life start a business find a
dream job one of the things we did was
um we decided early on that we are going
to be highly selective about who we
allow to be our customers oh I remember
highly selective yeah like a guy who was
like I'm going into credit card debt
buying your stuff and you go you're
banned you can't buy your stuff anymore
yeah I oh no I've banned thousands of
people thousands the DNS list stands for
do not sell and we have a very extensive
list of people who we simply will not
accept their money so policy number one
is if you have credit card debt you
cannot join our Flagship programs those
are the expensive ones why two reasons
one if if you actually understood how
credit card interest rates work you
would never spend two thousand dollars
on a program you would pay your debt off
first get financially comfortable right
and then come back to us and two the
type of people who join with credit card
debt they often have a lot of pressure
on like they go this has got to work I'm
down to my last dollar I go no you can't
make huge changes in life if you have
that kind of pressure so slow it down
here's a free chapter from my book and
like please don't join come back when
you're ready we'll be here if they still
join
and I think for any entrepreneur
listening you don't have to do the same
thing I do but the point is if you
really Elevate yourself you go hey I'm
spending tons of time building the best
product or service in the world
therefore I'm going to be selective
about who I allow to join my business
like Hermes very selective about who
they allow to buy their birken back
think about elevating yourself make sure
that you're actually good enough to
elevate yourself and then be selective
it actually builds a much better and
more profitable business you say uh
don't be the first mover wait to write a
book start making money follow your
natural tendencies uh so for example I
love slow long-term thinking
um so that's what you're gonna do and
you so you'd be horrible at starting
clubs in Miami and then you have a
framework of fast deep and long
um what so if I I agree with the first
mover thing the write a book thing I
actually agree with too writing a book
seems like a pain in the ass by the way
and what start making money what do you
mean
well I think that sometimes we um people
believe I need to build up like this
huge long um audience before I start
making money and that's actually what I
did and I in retrospect it caused me a
lot of hardship uh because I was writing
for free in 2004 five six and when I
finally sold something for five dollars
is a 4.95 eBook I was petrified of
selling I had a pretty decent sized
audience and a lot of people got pissed
off at me really mad because they
basically saw me as the free information
guy and when I tried to redefine the
Dynamics of that relationship people do
not like that it would have been much
better if I'd started off and I was like
hey this is actually going to be a
business uh it would have taught me like
focus on the metrics that matter focus
on things that matter and it also would
have set the expectation with my
audience so I went through a lot like I
went through two and a half three years
of people unsubscribing for my list
every day I was using aweber at the time
so you can see see the reasons that they
unsubscribe so every morning I woke up
there's like 75 people they're like you
suck yourself out and I was like wait
what I still give away 98 of my stuff
for free I'm selling a five dollar ebook
and they were Furious and that was my
fault not theirs
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better we I have
so many people who ask me they're like
I'm gonna do a newsletter when do I
monetize I usually tell them or a
podcast whatever I usually tell them I'm
like this is a huge generalization but
for a newsletter maybe when you're at
five or ten thousand people then you
could have an ad if you could have an ad
in it if you're just selling like a
product [__] do it right away like
day one have it in there yeah um and
they're like I should do it that early
won't I like turn off my audience I'm
like no you won't but you need that
money in order to do more [__] and I'm
like also if you turn off your audience
doing this it's the wrong thing I
remember Casey neistat Casey neistat um
my favorite you know he's I love him he
had uh this video where he said I was uh
he talks about money and he goes I was
like at Peak Fame in like 2016 and he
goes I was still broke because even
though I had even though I had all of
these downloads and people thought I was
famous I didn't have any money and he
goes I thought I was being a cool artist
by not having YouTube ads on but I went
back and did the math that was like uh
four or five million dollars a year that
I was missing out on and I was [__]
broke and it I was an idiot and so if
you're an artist out there don't be a
fool take the money because then you
could keep doing more art
listen to Sam I wish I had learned that
Sam like early on I didn't I had the
same sort of thinking like oh my gosh
monetizing will turn people off and what
I didn't realize is first of all if
you're turning them off by trying to
make a living then you've got the wrong
audience better to know that early than
later and a lot of times people actually
like it like they want to know what you
recommend so that was interesting but
most of all if you have money it enables
you to Build a Better Business better
people better design better Talent
better all of it and I didn't get that
for a few years I wish I had
uh we'll wrap up in a second because I
know you're we're at the hour but one
last question which is
uh sometimes people come to me and
they'll be like you know my personal
brand is really tied up in my company's
brand and that will make it hard because
maybe I want to sell my company
so have you ever thought about selling I
will teach you to be rich would you ever
sell it and is it sellable being so tied
to you
I don't think it's sellable in the way
that I would need to maintain my
reputation I have had some interest in
selling the business
um I remember I got invited I was at a
party in New York and this kind of
mysterious guy comes up to me and he had
a very generic name and he he was like
oh nice to meet you but he knew a lot
about my business like more than any
normal person would know he knew like
the way I structured my funnels he knew
basic conversion rates I was like who in
the hell is this guy he goes hey I'm
gonna be in town in a couple weeks I'd
love to get together for breakfast I was
like cool
so you know I was like pretty young guy
I was working at a coffee shops stuff
like that he invites me to the Four
Seasons in Midtown for breakfast I was
like what the hell you knew how to
tickle your family man you like fancy
hotels yeah I was like hmm okay let's go
so we get there and uh it's four people
including me at the table three other
[__] ambush
so I was like
cool like this is weird but like let's
let's do I don't know what's going on
here so I'm chatting with the guy he's
very nice and one guy's uh kind of like
silent and the other guy is sitting
there with his arms Crossing just
listening and I'm trying to figure out
like what's the power Dynamic here
what's going on
and at one point one of the guys the guy
with the crossed arms who wasn't saying
much
um he mentioned that he like vacations
in North Carolina or something like that
and I go oh like how far is the place
from the airport
I don't know why I asked that question
but we're talking about it and he said
something like oh it's like a five hour
drive I go wow that's a long drive he
goes oh I don't drive I take a
helicopter Bingo oh got it okay God now
I understand what's going on so they
wanted to buy
a percentage of the business over 50
percent and they wanted to you know
basically hyper monetize it now my
business could make a lot more money if
I got more aggressive with my offers we
don't really run Facebook ads so for us
to win on Facebook we would need to get
much more aggressive than we're willing
to like I have a brand I have a
reputation also
I already have the name I will teach you
rich I actually love when people come
they expect to get this Hard Sell and
they're like oh this guy went to
Stanford he has a Netflix show like you
can get his book A lot of it for free
like it's you know it's it kind of
you're like oh I'm surprised I didn't
sell I told him Point Blank and I even
thought to myself like what would I do
with the money my life is great I had an
assistant
I had a trainer I was like I'm good like
what am I gonna do with extra money
I'm actually really glad I did not sell
because the business went through a big
growth spurt in the next few years
but now I have the dream that I love I
have a 100 bootstrap business I work
from home my team is amazing and like I
get to go on
talk shows like this talk about my
philosophy and then people email me with
their
success stories I'm like dude it does
not get better than this I appreciate
every day that I have this business is
there any Financial or business goals
that you have as a North star where
you're like you know in 10 years it
would be cool if we did this
um I'm in a I guess I didn't expect
Netflix to happen like I was not gutting
for it it just happened so
um I wanted to reach more people that
was my goal and I've now reached more
people in the last week than I have in
probably 10 years which is like my I'm
still trying to sit with that
um so I probably need to recalibrate
where I want to go but I'll tell you
like one thing I know like from doing
the podcast is uh when I started the
podcast I sat down I wrote a vision
document I never really do this and I
wrote it because I knew that we were
going to have to get a lot of people
involved like uh editors and guests and
everybody and I was like you know what I
need to just write down my exact Vision
so I was like here's what the podcast is
here's 20 sample titles that I want to
do here's the type of people here's what
it's not it's not a podcast about
compound interest calculations and
when I wrote that
I realized that the number one the
podcast has to be fun for me if it's not
fun I'm not doing it and I would imagine
you have a similar thing like once you
make a certain amount of money you go
okay like what is the other meaning it's
got to be fun and if it's not or it's
not like reaching the right people
I'm just not into it wanna I you you
know for for everything bad he's done he
said something amazing which is Kanye
West said something uh he goes uh I do
dope [__] and uh or you know there he
was there's a story of him with Dave
Chappelle and Dave Chappelle's uh you
know Kanye's backstage at Dave Chappelle
Show someone calls Kanye and Dave is
retelling the story and Dave goes or
Connie goes hey yeah I can't really talk
right now
because I'm backstage with Dave
Chappelle watching never seen before
clips of the show right now and then he
goes
yeah because my life's dope and I do
dope [__] and he just hung up and uh and
then he like
and then and then he like you know like
in the past couple years he gave this
interview he's like money's cool but
like I just want to do dope [__] and he
like keeps repeating this like listen I
need to start talking like this now I'm
like I'm like what kind of celebrity
[__] do I need to say now that I have a
show like what do I need to know
meanwhile I'm just this internet dork
who sits on Twitter I make a joke about
real estate or asset allocation and then
I'm like all right that was a good day I
go take a nap on the couch I'm like um I
gotta learn what these guys are doing
well me and Sean have a joke but I I
truly live this way I'm like
would my 12 year old be proud of the
[__] that I'm doing now you know what I
mean like am I you guys like I've heard
you talk about this it's it's crazy when
you said it like that would my what your
12 year old self or my 12 year old self
like I heard you say this the other day
I went home I told my wife and I told
her
like my 12 year old or even 20 year old
self would not believe it would not
believe that I'm married to you
would not believe that we travel the way
we travel that I have a business like
this like a team that's like awesome you
can like talk like celebrities [__] yeah
it's awesome yeah yeah by the way I'm
getting these DMS from celebrities like
athletes you know I don't know anything
about sports right and they're always
like I saw you tweeted you're like I'm
from the Phillies or something
yeah I'm from the Eagles and I'm like is
that a basketball team and like they
don't even reply
oh funny when when um when Netflix
emailed me when the the first time they
emailed me they were like
oh hi like um you know we'd love to talk
to you about a project
um do you have representation or should
we like speak to you directly and I was
like what the hell is representation
like I didn't even know what they were
talking about like I didn't have a
entertainment lawyer I didn't know how
to find one I went on Google I literally
typed entertainment lawyer and I looked
through the list
like that's how I found an entertainment
lawyer and like I had to learn this
industry like seriously from the ground
up and then it took me like a couple of
years to truly start to scratch the
surface because in Silicon Valley it's
very different it's a way to Tweet
someone they'll take a meeting yeah it's
like but the industry Dynamics are
different like subtle things like for
example Engineers are kind of regaled as
like the most valuable okay well what's
the equivalent in Hollywood that's not
obvious from the outside and
um what are the like cultural mores it's
not obvious so dude I'm just at the very
beginning of Learning this stuff but
it's actually really cool to be a
student of a new industry and learn like
oh that's how things are done here and
oh there's actually kind of a reason why
we've just gotten popular enough now
that some of the agents you know like
the what's it CAA and I forget the other
three yeah uh there's like two or three
of them where they're actually starting
to talk to us
and I I'm incredibly turned off by the
whole process I I find it to be very
off-putting and I like I have to remind
myself well you know there could be a
reason why this exists and then I start
talking to them like well these guys
seem pretty nice and they're making a
lot of sense but then in the back of my
head I'm like these people are [__]
sharks they're gonna steal from you
they're gonna like you know like like
you know what I mean like it's like this
hard uh dichotomy uh wait we gotta talk
about this like if you ever want to like
chat about it because I know I know
these folks and
do you like it totally legit
um
yeah that's like a weird question are
they legit is like is a recruiter legit
I mean it depends for what you're going
for yeah if you you know you're in a
unique perspective because number one
you have this huge podcast you and Sean
have built this amazing thing and like
the personality the events you've built
is like crazy I mean I watch
from the early days and I've really
gotten into your podcast in the last
year and I'm just like oh you guys are
like firing on all cylinders you would
have no idea what you guys do best how
how fast it is by the way our events are
way more half-assed than you think
really dude the photos look incredible
they're great they're great but like
they're thrown together yeah really you
just show up and just like hang [__]
that's insane okay anyway it looks great
um
and then you're you know you already
have money so you're not like super
profit motivated unless it's like the
right opportunity it's you and Sean you
got HubSpot involved so there's a lot of
unique things but one thing I learned in
Hollywood is take the meeting always
take the meeting which is different
because I turned down nine out of ten
things I'm just like nope nope nope but
if you want it's all relationship based
way more than Tech way more
um just to give you an example a lot of
lawyers
um PR firms in Hollywood they will not
even take your call even if you're ready
to hire them like you have a fat check
they will not even take your call if
you're not referred by an agent or
someone else like that that's
mind-blowing that pisses me off you know
I love Jay Leno Jay Leno has this all
you're not into cars I don't think but
he's got this really cool show called
wait does having a Honda Accord not
count as being into cars unfortunately
not my friend uh it does not but Jay
Leno has this thing called Jay Leno's
garage and he tells you the history of
the car and why it's cool and he's got
those funny uh bit where he talks about
Ferrari he refused you know Jay Leno
probably has 500 or a thousand cars and
they're all like historical and
important and he goes someone was like
why aren't there any Ferraris here he
goes I refuse to buy a Ferrari and he
goes why he goes because they you have
to get on a wait list and you have to
like get on a waitlist to buy one in
order to buy the next one so in order to
buy like for example let's say there's
like a GTO 250 which is like a 30
million dollar car they only made five
of them whatever it's like this really
rare car and it's like an art and he's
like I would love to own one because I
think they're awesome but they make you
buy the entry level one then you have to
get on a waiting list to buy the next
one and you can't sell it you have to do
all these rules he goes I refuse to bow
down to that [__] and I'm not gonna
play that game I just wanna I I just now
he's like I realize it's not like the
every man I'm not like the every man but
in some regard like I just don't want to
like jump to the Hoops I just want to
say if I'm willing to give you money
please let me have it and so I refuse to
buy a Ferrari for that reason
I'm like Hermes I'm like dude I'm not
gonna get on a [__] list to buy this
[__] that's [__] yeah yeah I I agree
I respect that he is like no I'm not
gonna play that game I love that at the
same time I also understand why a luxury
business does that so there's a couple
of great books on luxury and and there's
this phrase um when the CEO of Volvo
sees two Volvos on a city block he's
happy when the CEO of
Porsche or Rolls-Royce sees to he gets
worried
and I think that that's right on luxury
is a totally different Beast it's a
totally different way of marketing you
don't want too many people to have it
and so you create these barriers
um by the way I listened to this uh this
Rolls Royce uh podcast so I like I love
I'm not like Rolls-Royce to me the look
of it is a little gaudy for me
and also I'm not really a car guy but
one day I'm gonna buy a sweet car like
it's gonna be amazing which people are
gonna be like this [__] guy told
maybe Bentley maybe Rolls-Royce like I
love the craftsmanship of it like the
Perfection of it and that's like that's
one of the reasons I love beautiful
clothes like they're handmade hand
stitched everything is absolutely
perfect I've gone to the factory in
Italy where I saw the absolutely
beautiful well-lit Factory floor and I
saw them making these beautiful cashmere
sweaters and I go I appreciate that they
are paying well that everything's done
by hand they have a school in solomeo
where they're teaching the next
generation of Artisans and Craftsmen
that's fantastic so I have a love of
craftsmanship
but anyway I'm listening to Rolls Royce
came out with a podcast which is genius
because if you're gonna buy a 500 000
car you're gonna listen and research
every Last Detail you can about the car
and I just I'm obsessed with the details
of the leather and the color matching
and you know if you get a custom color
on a Rolls-Royce it's now your color
nobody else can ever use it from
Rolls-Royce if they want it they have to
ask your permission to use it I'm like
okay that's cool not not for me today
maybe someday one day
what's the uh let's wrap up here but
tell me what's the uh what are the
luxury books I'm gonna write them down I
want to read them too all right so one
of them is called the luxury strategy
uh another one is called CAP fur on
luxury
and uh
those are two that'll get you started
I think those are really good ones cool
what are you reading right now
uh I'm reading a lot of stuff about the
mob about the mafia okay uh so I like
crime stuff uh I am um what else have I
read recently it's lots of crime stuff
unfortunately uh I'm re-reading a book
on Joseph Kennedy Joseph Kennedy you
know father of JFK he's a really
controversial person he basically got
rich off insider trading then became the
first head of the SEC made insider
trading illegal incredibly unfaithful to
his wife but kind of a really good
father so a lot of like interesting
things a lot of people don't know that
Joe Kennedy was like the seventh richest
person in America so JFK was like not
just wealthy but really wealthy so I'm
rereading a book on him and I'm
re-reading a book on the uh American
capitalism between 1910 and 1920 it was
highly unregulated so like the Andrew
carnegies of the world Jay Gould John
Rockefeller they were really fascinating
because it was like super Cutthroat and
so I'm rereading about that yeah let me
just share what I'm reading right now
too
um one is called unreasonable Hospital
reality and in that's the guy who used
to run a very high-end restaurant in New
York another one is called customers for
life this is by a guy who ran an auto
dealership just like really nitty-gritty
business I just love that
um I got one called the power of the
past this is awesome for anyone who
listens to my podcast you'll hear me
talk about money and class class is not
really talked about in America but it
exists it's the power of the past by
Jesse stribe and then
um
uh color of law is when I'm rereading on
real estate redlining and race in
history so anyway those are a couple few
books I'm reading over me I like this
yeah dude I was just thinking I just
wrote a note I should have a podcast
just on books just asking like
interesting people what they're reading
and why oh dude I would
I would love that well I've just your
first listener and I'll definitely come
on that's a great idea yeah I mean
because that's always like a one of my
favorite Parts is ask people what
they're reading and why
um but dude I appreciate you doing this
man you're you're the man I thank you
for your friendship thank you for doing
this congratulations on the show it's
freaking awesome my wife and I were
watching thank you all day yesterday uh
really oh my God I sent you the video of
us you sent me that
dude to know that you guys are watching
this which I spent like years doing kept
it quiet for that long and to know that
it's like inside your house and the two
of you are connecting over it like
honestly the highest praise for someone
who creates anything so thank you it
means a lot it was awesome and I
appreciate you doing this thanks for
everything thank you dude that's the pod
[Music]